the Joe Rogan experience but going to it
but I knew I was right I knew I was like
Donna what the [ __ ] he doing I'm scared
son
I know but look it worked it worked you
know and I flew you you don't have your
own map that's my son's hair right there
show everybody your master the mask oh
yeah this is a Donna Rossi show oh we
got merchandise for y'all punk
[ __ ] now this is the what is it
say on it wait a minute it says hold on
it says the donnell rawlings show on one
side what is that what's up right the
other side o donnell rawlings other side
says not today bro that did a runner
it won't happen today and if you see yo
looks alright i'ma tell you i'ma tell
you what happens this is a tough time
for everybody nobody won't take their
head off right and y'all I've been
feeling it right and I was I will never
act a Hollywood again if I do this right
so I start going you'll see I'm a behind
it burns I got the [ __ ] sunroof
sunroof no I got a sunroof sunroof yo
but your sunroof should make it 50
meters a year this is not the same roof
you know I've said this is a this is a
hoody roof right here so I cut my son's
hair right and I was like oh [ __ ] what
can I do right he saw he was like ah
so I say I'm gonna [ __ ] around I take
you to the show and I'm gonna get a glue
stick and put it on my head just for fun
he thought it would be funny and I
showed him this podcast I'm the other
day and he got excited about it but the
thing I liked about me having a hit it
smells like him so it's like a souvenir
and right there you know what Joe I
don't want to feel like I'm CBS or
anything right now but I want to say we
all know when it comes to Corona there's
certain things that go before you know
if you have Corona or you kind of feel
it right your sense of smell and your
sense of test that's why Joe you're not
gonna believe this right I came up I
came up with a one-of-a-kind this is a
specific to me it's the diner Ollie show
okay now I'm not enough you familiar
with a smell called black ice
do you know a black I said no you know
what black ice I don't know I wouldn't
lie to you no you don't really know what
the black ice air freshener is I don't
think so
do you know what it is you don't know
okay you're gonna I bet you'll know this
I mean okay it's like for a car all
right you know this one you know the
Royal pine air freshener yeah there's a
little change the white one let me just
tell you right off the bow of my Hut
listen I'm a car freak I hate air
fresheners
I don't like them right I want to smell
car I want to say that about I want to
smell gasoline and your carpet it's not
about your car like you've not been into
a Cadillac a black a black owned
Cadillac you'd never had a ride with
Snoop Doggy any of the hip-hop dudes
right a dog in the culture black culture
black ice is just the smell you always
have to have it in your car if you want
to get some [ __ ] back in a day oh my
god it's a tree though yeah it's a tree
the same [ __ ] is the same with the white
man's air freshener it's the same shape
it's the black lives matter of air
fresheners Joe it is hilarious though
they pretend look it's like a tree made
out of chemicals but Joe it's like the
woods Joe I don't want to distract be
getting back because a candle this is
the Donna rods candle right and I want
to check them and one of my arm Whitney
Whitney Cummings has one Angela Yee hair
one they'll check it out tell me what
you think oh that smells good um Jamie
so you know what let me smell it it
smells see that's the other thing this
is a this this candle helps you doin
corona like you burn that count and the
minute you don't smell it [ __ ] go get a
test
but more importantly Joe more
importantly Joe
it's could you read the description
could you read a description and the
ingredients in it is [ __ ] back here yes
sir from Marcy projects to Hollywood
Donnell captured six true smells oils
going from ashy to classy breathe in the
memories of cold air hitting your skin
on a winter's day shades of your skin
getting a shear and a shear as the brisk
wind hit your arms and ankles captured
the energy of a good lotion without
having it black ash eliminates the smell
of torque and replaces it with his
exotic smells the ingredients Joe I
don't know the first one what does that
bergamot bergamot I don't know what that
is
do you know what that is bergamot we
sandalwood I've heard of that Musk
uh-huh Elan lavender jasmine and amber
good game burgers
ambergris ambergris in this okay am
because this is where um cuz I have a
really professional person that does
these cans right amber yes and I was
talking to somebody there's really a
health nut into raw stuff amber this
what else I heard ambergris was at first
it was sperm from a well I knew usually
get excited about this key what I
thought about it this is what I heard
first it was sperm from a whale that
they mined for right but come to find
out it wasn't I thought it was I was
like oh [ __ ] my candle get a weld nut
right but it's not that it's the
byproduct of an actual sperm whale do
you know when the nobility no please
cruelty that's the most it's the load
out of the way without being see that's
when the story started to just that's
what the story got flaky you know I mean
I needed to know more I was like who was
jerking the West 60,000 giant [ __ ]
pop-up ads you son of a [ __ ] oh you
have to give them an email
oh shut up I know you got somewhere else
um funny because I was gonna say is that
Red Bull
we found out that Red Bulls made with
taurine and the original source of
taurine they said get it from bull test
goals really Bowl nuts yeah like Hitler
apparently was into taurine cool nuts
yeah yeah ooh it's like some form of
testosterone or something or some form
of stimulant well anything that has
something to do with sperm it feels like
I supposed to give you super super
stripping some people are silly
ambergris how to tell if you've struck
gold with the whale vomit or stumbled
upon sewage oh so sometimes you they
find it like floating around yeah oh is
it thought I thought it was sperm so I
was like who the [ __ ] is swimming
through oh my god look at that [ __ ] it
it can be up to 71 thousand dollars for
a 1.57 kilogram lump that's like three
three and a half pounds right so I'm
like this is a lava what is the whale
what what is it the well it said whale
vomit so it's like truffle yes look I
knew it
I know it's compared to [ __ ] truffles
mmm my [ __ ] my candle got truffle each
type [ __ ] ambergris soprano sperm
whale that's what it is scroll back up a
little bit there Jimmy and is no cruelty
nobody beat the [ __ ] of the whale it's
not whale sperm it's a product of the
sperm whales that's not only a sperm
whale makes the compound responsible for
ambergris alors it's called Ambreen and
different organisms biosynthesized
different compounds such as caffeine
maybe cocoa coffee or tea plants Ambreen
is made by sperm whales only to glue
together squid beaks what the so what
you fan now Joe is my candle is baller
as [ __ ] look at this and the rest of it
listen to our service squid is the main
diet of sperm whales but the beaks can't
be digested they need to be passed out
without causing injury and they do this
by coating them with Ambreen so the
sperm whale creates this amazing [ __ ]
just to dissolve beaks of squids or to
be a mother [ __ ] candle god damn
nature's and to be my [ __ ] camera
my black ass
[Applause]